Now, for that tent, "The Cave."
That thing was cool.
It has these inflatable geometric support braces...
...that make it look kind of like a spider.
All you have to do is plug in the pump and pump it up.
However, it wasn't quite as easy to set up as it should have been.
The tent has these air valves around the base...
...which are kind of tough to spot when the tent is deflated.
And if you miss one, you just pump forever and never get anywhere.
But after I found and closed all of them, the tent went up with just a few pumps.
So the first time might be a little tough,...
...but once you know what you're doing, The Cave is a great tent.
And it ought to be since it's about 750 dollars.